vous êtes en train de me dit que vous
étiez un wc les incompétents beaucoup de
jeu je pense pas être imbécile je pense
pas être incompétent non plus huit et
cinq ou six jouets petit contest ait des
gens qui viennent parce qu'ils espèrent
peut-être avoir un retour d'ascenseur
je m'aime pas le dit c'est toi c'est
quoi la mafia de mathias est choquant
qu'une culture c'est ce que nous qui
volent beaucoup de témoignages beaucoup
de souvenirs c'est donc la fin des
audiences de la commission charbonneau
l'exercice qui s'est échelonnée sur plus
de deux ans aura coûté 35 millions sept
cent quarante cinq mille dollars aux
contribuables jusqu'à maintenant dans
l'entente dans cette semaine l'avocat de
la ftq construction dire qu'il ya pas de
problème à traiter avec un employeur
faisant partie du crime organisé s'il
s'agit simplement de discuter de
conditions de travail
certains se sont tout de même demandé
tout ça pour ça alors tu achats et à
toronto
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir daniel
michel avec moi sur ce plateau bonsoir à
vous trois donc ça aura coûté deux fois
plus plus que prévu michel est ce que
c'était un exercice utile oui je pense
que oui et tout ça a été je pense un
examen collectif salutaire c'est un choc
même à souvenez-vous au début les gens
ont été abasourdis parole on savait
qu'il y avait des corruptions me
l'ampleur du phénomène a vraiment
surpris tout le monde
mais là je comprends qu'une certaine
déception parce que je pense que dans
l'esprit des gens il ya comme un
malentendu sur le rôle de cette
commission là les gens le voyait comme
un espèce de tribunal où tous les ripoux
de montréal et les durs est sale est
pendu sur la place publique alors que
c'était pas ça l'objet de deux comme ça
c'était vraiment de voir comment ça
fonctionnait et il se trouve même qu'un
certain courage pour une société à se
mettre à nu comme ça je convaincu qu'il
ya bien des endroits yahoo si on faisait
le même exercice
on arriverait à d
résultat qui serait assez aussi
spectaculaire que cela maintenant
l'utilité va aussi dépendre beaucoup de
la suite des choses
par exemple vous donne juste un exemple
rapide on sait de façon assez certaine
qu une des raisons pourquoi la collusion
la corruption se sont installés comme ça
c'est la perte d' expertise tant dans
les villes et municipalités à montréal
en particulier et au gouvernement du
québec
si pour des raisons budgétaires on se
dit bon on n'a pas les moyens d'engager
ses ingénieurs là qu'ils vont faire en
sorte que ces pôles privé qui va
continuer à surveiller de priver bah ça
ça va revenir
c'est clair alors il va faire avoir de
la volonté politique de mettre en oeuvre
les moyens qui est d'être intéressant
mais quand même on a appris beaucoup de
choses daniel est ce qu'on est allé plus
loin que les enquêtes journalistiques
sans ces enquêtes et fin les alain
gravel de ce mot n'y aurait probablement
pu y aura sûrement pas eu de commission
charbonneau saintil point de départ et
c'était très important
elles ont appris des choses on a appris
que aya il ya 40 ans il y avait eu la
commission aux clichés qui avait mis à
jour tout un scandale dans le domaine de
la construction ou la ftq est impliqué
saccage de la baie james
aussi bon le juge riche avec moroni guy
chevrette a tout réglé on va avoir la
paix paris la commission gomery et 28
ans et encore les mêmes problèmes de
collusion et la commission charbonneau
découvre encore les mêmes problèmes de
collusion et de corruption
c'est comme si on apprenait jamais c'est
comme de la mauvaise herbe ça revient et
sans arrêt à c'est assez désolant
espérons que cette fois il y aura des
recommandations qu'elle soit précise
qu'elles seront rigoureuse et que le
gouvernement surtout de mettre en place
tasha faut quand même se remettre dans
le contexte le djia ya deux ans cette
thérapie collective si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi a été quand même utile
et nécessaire
oui je pense que auprès pas s'en passer
si on s'enfermait dans la situation où
il y avait des demandes presque
quotidiennes de la paix soient de
l'opposition ou des journalistes où le
public même qu'on ait une enquête dans
la situation et quand finalement
monsieur charest avait créé la
commission charbonneau
je pense y avait un certain soulagement
que peut-être maintenant on allait
savoir la vérité ça allait sortir
et comme comme tu as dit céline dion peu
là une thérapie on n'a pas eu des
résultats
fulgurante sur le point de vue de faire
un lien définitif entre la corruption la
politique le financement et le monde de
la construction
mais ce qu'on a appris à régler
plusieurs problèmes notamment au niveau
des municipalités ou maintenant on a une
réglementation plus fort pour s'assurer
ou essayer que la situation et des
désordres 3 de contrat ici et là non
méritée ne se reproduit pas est-ce qu'on
lutte allait cependant au bout de
l'exercice ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
restés sur leur faim parce que justement
sur le financement politique michel on
n'a peut-être pas interroger certaines
personnes qu'on croyait peut-être qu'il
n'a pu se présenter à la commission je
pense à jean charest je pense à un
niveau le grand argentier encore une
fois je pense les genres et messali voir
des fils ils allaient voir passer un
espèce de sanction n'a été obligé de se
présenter devant la commission c'est
presque une punition mais je pense pas
qu'on aurait appris grand chose de plus
souvenez vous la commission gomery ce
pas parce que jean chrétien est allé
comparu qu'on a appris plus de choses
sur la façon dont ça fonctionnait je
vais les balles de golf mais vous voyez
dans le cas des villes en a eu lie les
gros morceaux se faisaient les gros
poissons il ya eu la maire tremblay le
maire vaillancourt mais d'un caddie
ville
le lien entre le politique et l'octroi
des contrats était et est très très
étroite avec monsieur pinault on l'a vu
avec monsieur vaillancourt ce qu'on a
appris de ce qui se passait au niveau du
québec c'est que l'ailier était beaucoup
plus ténu il y avait tout le filtre de
l'appareil administratif ne sorte que la
relation de cause à effet entre l'octroi
de contrats et le financement des partis
politiques était beaucoup plus difficile
à démontrer dans ce colloque dans le cas
des municipalités alors que monsieur
chrétien soit allée où monsieur bibou ça
monsieur que c'est monsieur charest ne
se vit bouge pas sa réponse dans les
grand chose de plus
ben non je suis entièrement d'accord
avec michel jean chrétien ont fait la
preuve que bon c'est un spectacle et
c'était beaucoup plus pour deux
spectacles c'était amusant et même de
jeu gomery a choisi d'en rire parce que
on avait on aurait obtenu quoi de jean
charest il il aurait été quoi quand on
n'avait pas déjà entendu
même chose avec bibeau ces gens là
savent comment jouer ce jeu-là la
perfection alors coûté ah oui ça aurait
fait un beau spectacle
mais est ce que c'était vraiment
nécessaire serait fait le tour du
dossier ça aurait permis le roi bien des
gens disent bon premier ministre savait
peut-être pas autant qu'on le pensait
jean chrétien sans la colère de savoir
que chaque guité a mené une opération
complètement palais correct et cetera
mais en bout de piste
est-ce que ça va empêcher madame chabot
nous de faire toutes les recommandations
qu'elle veut je crois quand même ça fait
baisser les prix des contrats en phase
des travaux publics
jenny ont quand même souffert beaucoup
d'achats oui oui certainement et à
écouter on a eu un bouleversement dans
ces secteurs des grandes firmes qui ont
vu d'énormes changements et à cause des
révélations qui ont été faits je pense
pour le public c'est un type de
nettoyage un peu qui s'est fait je pense
si on n'avait pas eu cette commission et
a toujours eu la grande question dans la
tête des gens la spéculation
jusqu'à quel point est-ce qu'on a un
problème entre les gains entre
financement la politique les uns des
ingénieurs les firmes d'ingénierie la
construction et cetera maintenant on
sait au moins si on est peut-être aller
au bout mais on est allé assez loin je
pense pour que le public soit au moins
un peu satisfait qu'il ya un progrès qui
a été fait mais pour notre ego collectif
ça a été dur ça passe les firmes de
génie-conseil ans a toujours été la
fierté du québec
souvenez-vous les premières avec l'hydro
et tout çà et là les déboulonner comme
ça je pensais être un choc et même sur
le plan pratique il y a des parts par
exemple des sceaux qui a été acheté par
un firme albertaine
il ya des pertes de contrôle
c'est lavalin que se défendent de
contrôle importante là dedans qui sont
déplorables
bon parlons de la mise à jour économique
du gouvernement stephen harper retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire l'an prochain des
surplus moins considérable que prévu
quand même en raison des mesures déjà
annoncées comme le fractionnement des
revenus pour les familles daniel au delà
des chiffres quand même un exercice de
stratégie politique pour le porno
absolument l'exercice très habile il
faut dire on aime ou on aime pas s'il
venait à peu cette partie de hockey lah
ici comment la jouer il ajouterait bien
il joue de façon [ __ ] s'il était dans
une équipe d'air qui se serait le goût
qu'on amène pour gagner et là mais c'est
très oui c'est dur mais c'est très
habile je lui reconnais ça il ay là il a
déjà dépensé tous les surplus les
pauvres partis d'opposition maintenant
au mont d'orzeires nous on va céder les
baisses d'impôts quelque chose de
difficile à faire c'est très bien ça et
et héééé après les fausses se retrouver
dans un coin avec pour beaucoup
d'options à celui qui contrôle tout le
jeu en ce moment depuis un mois les
sondages ne font monter tranquillement
km a devancé justin trudeau dans la
popularité des chefs pour les intentions
de vote mais la confiance au chef des
événements l'on est né récemment mes
tâches a quand même c'est vrai qu'il ne
laisse pas beaucoup de marge de
manoeuvre la aux partis d'opposition
oui mais qu'est ce que vous voulez je
trouve cette scic logique un peu absurde
que les partis d'opposition se plaignent
n'y a pas de surplus ce que eux puissent
dépenser essentiellement mais est-ce que
c'est eux qui ont remis l'équilibré
budgétaire ils se sont opposés à toutes
les coupures que les gouvernements ont
le gouvernant a fait pour atteindre ces
surplus budgétaires et les gouvernants
aussi avait promis les conservateurs si
on se rappelle en 2011 avait dit qu'on
va apporter le partage des revenus le
fractionnement des revenus
les noms de sa maison c'est ça ils ont
tenu les promesses qu'est ce que vous
voulez ce qu'ils tiennent pas leurs
promesses alors dans un sens c'est
ridicule pour les oppositions de se
plaindre et dire nous on veut dépenser
l'argent que vous avez économisé eux il
aurait dépensé s'il avait de la même
façon mais ça va être difficile de
revenir en arrière
pas nécessairement de la même façon les
dépenses évitées
le ministre des finances jan lievens et
vanter d'offrir aux canadiens la
taxation la plus basse depuis john
diefenbaker est ce qu il ya de quoi
vraiment se réjouir parce que dont je
comprends que les contribuables qui vont
recevoir 20 bel20 peau ou un chèque
location vont très content mais se
réjouir de la réduction de la capacité
d'agir de l'étop moi je pense que c'est
une bonne nouvelle
je parle même pas d'une crise qui par
exemple serait un gouvernement sans les
moyens de réagir mais même dans le
quotidien je comprends que c'est moins
spectaculaire que des coupures dans les
hôpitaux ou dans les écoles mais prenait
5 le marché pas l'inspection des viandes
ou l'environnement les deux jours on va
se retrouver peut-être dieu nous en
préserve
avec un nouveau walter on va dire ben
moody on en arrivait esprit exactement
la crise de l'eau on a répondu sacrifier
l'ex-parti du gouvernement alors il ya
une indication des responsabilités pour
des raisons purement aider à la survie
politique ferroviaire surveillance du
trafic sont partis beaucoup de
scientifiques partis à l'environnement
c'est décompression il a fait des choix
ce sont des choix idéologiques et il a
été élu on savait que s'il venait à
reprendre dans cette direction là et
c'est sa politique et heroes s'il n'ya
pas d'hypocrisie c'est clair c'est net
et précis
est ce que ce sont des décisions
justifiable on peut débattre
après quand même ça peut avoir un prix
ces compressions la tâche mais de
compression peut avoir un prix c'est
vrai à date
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on a vu un autre
work chaîne on écoute les autres partis
d'opposition c'est parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de marge de manoeuvre
la prochaine fois ils peuvent renverser
certaines dépenses du gouvernement sur
les prisons par exemple ou sur les
avions de chasse il te dire on va
reprendre ces items du budget on ne va
pas dépenser ces sommes là on va les
octroyer aux garderies ou aux
scientifiques ou n'importe quoi alors
dire
limite leur choix n'est pas vrai ils ont
des choix mais politiquement faut avoir
le courage aussi peut-être de renverser
les choix des conservateurs est-ce
qu'ils ont ce courage c'est la question
ça va avoir des conséquences sur les
provinces il fait parce que ils
l'imposent dans le fond sa cure de
minceur aux provinces parce qu'à partir
du moment oui à tous toutes les surplus
apparaissent il est dit les remet aux
contribuables plutôt que de les envoyer
aux provinces où la sont les besoins ils
fassent les provinces à couper dans des
dans l'est dans la santé l'éducation
afin par toutes les provinces ont
augmenté les impôts les provinces mais
prenons le fractionnement l'époque
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour récupérer
chalon aussi mais à partir de demain il
ya un impôt sur les familles tous ceux
qui ont des enfants qui ont profité des
largesses de dollars on va leur vol est
taxé le québec va indexer le prix des
garderies par exemple c'est des choix de
société qui s'impose parce qu'on peut
pas toujours demeuré sur l'application
aux demandes et aux restes ya aussi de
financer les programmes alors il ya des
choix de société qui se font des choix
mais il lui sont imposées par le
gouvernement fédéral mais j'espère
terminer ce qui est quand même comme
gilles daniela rôle pour l'état de
compenser justement les écarts entre les
régions entre les provinces etc
gouvernement fédéral mais là où je
rejoins d'achat jusqu'à un certain point
qu'ils sont nombreux à ottawa à dire il
faut que les promesses il vit surtout le
québec et l'ontario en ce moment il faut
que les provinces fassent aussi leur
ménage il faut qu'ils prennent les
décisions difficiles
ça fait trop longtemps qu'on remet cette
notion d'assainissement des finances
publiques tous les gouvernements disent
on va le faire on va le faire aux
affaires n'est jamais rien qui se passe
donc si ça doit se faire aussi mais le
fédéral a un rôle à jouer et s'assurer
qu'il n'ya pas d'inéquité d'un boot à
l'eau
oui très bien alors on se laisse là
dessus où vous entendrez pas ce soir en
tout cas mais c'est pas grave c'est très
intéressant
merci beaucoup à vous croire à la fin de
l'année ça va